[Music]
foreign
here in this video we are going to
Showcase seven gigantic crocodiles from
movies and shows that are freaking
awesome the crocodiles are one of the
best yet least visited monster designs
and the ones they are come out with
flying colors I'm just saying that we
need more of these so let's get to this
list
at number seven we have the gigantic
crocodile from the movie Rogue in the
2007 Australian horror film Rogue a
group of tourists in Australia's
Northern Territory encounters a massive
25 feet or almost 8 meter long man
eating crocodile while on a river cruise
led by a wildlife researcher called Kate
Ryan the group becomes stranded on a
small island after their boat is damaged
by a crocodile they learned that they
must leave before the rising Tides
emerges the island and as night falls
one of the locals and Kate attempts to
create a zip line for the other group
members to cross the river however they
are attacked and killed by the crocodile
eventually a planet is made to lure the
creature while the others swim to safety
in a final confrontation Pete impales
the crocodile with a sharp law killing
him and he escapes the cave with Kate
and reunites with the other tourists and
paramedics
number six Gustav from Primeval in the
2007 American horror movie called
primeval the primary antagonist monster
is Gustav a legendary man eating
crocodile in the African country of
Burundi a group of American tourists
embossed on a mission to capture and
document a fearsome creature however
Gustav turns the table on them by
relentlessly stalking the group and
killing them one by one described as a
massive dark gray Nile crocodile Gustav
measures just over 9 meters or 30 feet
in length and weighs over a ton despite
appearing defeated and after being
stabbed in the mouth with a machete the
credits of the movie Reveal that Gustav
is still alive the movie is inspired by
the real-life crocodile called Gustav
who holds a mythical status among the
local population of the region according
to rumors the actual Gustav has claimed
the lives of up to 300 individuals and
is believed to be at least 60 years old
number five Lake placid's male crocodile
the male crocodile was the largest
crocodile to appear in all the Lake
Placid movies measuring approximately 9
meters or 30 feet in length this
particular crocodile is an Asian Pacific
crocodile and estimated to be over 150
years old the movie doesn't explain how
the male crocodile along with the other
female ones managed to reach Blake Lake
but it suggested that it somehow swam
from another continent to the Pacific
Ocean its skin has a dark black texture
with hints of brown although it is
unclear which crocodile specifically
killed the fish and game officer and
Deputy Burke in the beginning of the
movie the male crocodile is the
prominent threat throughout the story
interestingly while the movie is often
described as featuring a saltwater
crocodile it actually portrays the male
crocodile as a species of an Asian
Pacific one
number four Peter Pan's tick-top the
crocodile this is a monstrous creature
residing on Neverland after devouring
Captain Hook's hand which he lost in a
battle would be the pan Tick Tock
developed an insatiable craving for the
villainous Byron in a scene from the
movie Tick Tock appears and emerges from
underwater with Captain Hook position
over him threatening Peter Pan's life
instantly the crocodile lunges to
consume hook causing some of his Pirates
to retreat in fear while Tick-Tock
corners and devours the pirate who
attacked him witnessing this Mr Smee and
the remaining Pirates hastily escaped to
avoid meeting the same fate Tick Tock
proceeds to destroy the robot that hook
and his crew was using and continues to
hunt Captain Hook this crop in this
year's Peter Pan movie which is called
Peter Pan and Wendy measures over 40
feet long or 12 meters
number three the mandalorians Dinosaur
turtle the 50 meters are 165 feet long
dinosaur total was a large aggressive
reptilian creature I thought it was kind
of wild and lacked sentience it posed a
threat to the mandalorians attacking and
consuming some of them however their
encounters with the creature came to an
end when didn't jarin arrived with his
N1 Starfighter and large Torpedoes
ultimately killing the creature this
quadrupedal creature possessed a long
tail and had a highly resilient skin
that could withstand blast the fire its
shell was also strong enough to resist
the explosion of thermal detonators
while primarily dwelling underwater it
was capable of operating on land as well
concept art for the dinosaur till was
crafted and special effects were added
to enhance the creature's presence
during post-production with the actors
simulating combat against a large
Monster by looking at thin air
number two Lizzy from rampage this
monster crop was a byproduct of an
accident in the movie after a satellite
exploded a capsule containing an
experimental project Rampage pathogen
crashed into Florida's Everglades
National Park a crocodile swallowed the
capsule triggering a transformation the
crocodile turned into a colossal monster
known as Lizzy which was 200 feet or 60
meters in size when a beacon was
activated in Chicago Lizzie along with
other infected creatures swam towards
the city the monster easily overcame the
military resistance and scale Willis
Tower causing it to collapse in the
chaos Lizzie George a gorilla and Ralph
a wolf began fighting each other in The
Showdown Lizzy devout Ralph's head and
targeted Davis a character in the movie
but George the gorilla sacrificed
himself to save Davis Davis then used
various weapons against Lizzie but she
remained resilient eventually George
invade Lizzy's eye with a melt Spike
killing her and number one Pacific Rims
ride you okay so yeah this isn't really
a crocodile or an animal from Earth but
neither was the Dinosaur turtle from the
Mandalorian and also Tick Tock was from
Neverland Raiju is an aquaticaju from
the antiverse from Pacific Rim
resembling a mix of Galapagos iguana and
a crocodile it is heavily armed along
its back and head with a unique
tripartite jaw that protects its
bioluminescent head inside of it the
creatures Bend feeds and tail enable it
to swim swiftly under the ocean Raiju
emerges from the bridge alongside skana
and Zlatan to defend it from Gypsy
danger and Striker Eureka while the
Jaegers approached the portal Raju
stalks them from the darkness it joins
scanner in attacking Gypsy danger
ripping off its right arm before the
Jaeger can defeat skana Raju then
prepares for a second attack but Gypsy
dangerous Pilots receive a warning and
position the remaining gd6 chainsaw
accordingly so Raju impales itself on
the sword and Gypsy danger uses this
momentum to slice the Kaiju in half
effectively killing it
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel take care
fam